hey guys this next clip was made
possible by news voice which is a
democratized news app created to fight
back against the filter bubbles caused
by corporate media download for free
from news voice calm slash Pakman or
click the link under this video I've
talked to you before about political
footballs an example would be the right
doesn't actually care about debt and
deficit they care about it to the extent
that they can use it as a political
football or a cudgel to push Democrats
around and to try to get people elected
and to criticize left-leaning
politicians the right doesn't really
care about the demand for abortions
they're against abortions and they want
to make abortion services illegal
because that helps them raise money but
they don't actually want to do the
things that reduce the number of
abortions that women demand like for
example reducing unintended pregnancy
which is just sort of a basic basic
thing they use it as a political
football or a cudgel to push people
around and along the same lines the
right doesn't care about civility and
tone they claim to care about that but
they really don't and in the context of
these recent pipe bombs that were sent
to the Clintons and to the Obamas and to
George Soros and to former CIA director
John Brennan and to debbie Wasserman
Schultz and Maxine Waters and Robert De
Niro's restaurant senator Ted Cruz
called for civility well very nice he
tweeted the other day quote violence is
never okay reports of bombs sent to the
homes of Obama Clinton and Soros are
deeply deeply disturbing America is
better than this political disagreements
are fine even healthy but we should
always be civil and respecting each
other's humanity
that's my Ted Cruz impression pretty
good so okay he's in the Pro civility
movement cool wait a second 24 hours
before tweeting that he called for the
imprisonment of Democrats without them
having been convicted of suspected of
charged with or prosecuted for any
crimes whatsoever is that civil this was
at a rally in Georgetown Texas the at
mention of his opponent Beto O'Rourke
the audience started shouting lock him
up why would you lock up Beto O'Rourke I
have absolutely no idea take a look at
this photo he would not stand with
well you know there's a gutter occupancy
cell
[Applause]
I saw two people in the crowd by the way
wearing these American flag shirts were
the shirt the entire shirt it doesn't
have a picture of the flag the entire
shirt is like a flag there were people
wearing those at Politico and
interestingly enough and that's against
US flag code it's just as bad as
kneeling for the national anthem oh
absolutely
so anyway Ted Cruz complains about the
lack of civility and then he is a nut
and he is audience cheer chants about
locking up bet over Roarke with Hillary
Clinton if it's serious is that civil if
it's a joke is that civil like either
way you have a crowd here chanting lock
him up without even claiming that he
committed any prime crime with Kavanagh
they were all about innocent until
proven guilty
how can anyone suggest that Christine
Blasi Ford is telling the truth until it
has been proven in a court of law
what happened to that with vetto
O'Rourke why are people calling for him
to be locked up and that's why I get
back to another opportunity Pat to say
what please vote please vote early
voting has started in Texas you can go
vote right now well depends what time of
day you're watching or listening to this
and if you live in Texas and oh yes you
should live in Texas if you're gonna do
it or have residency there and be voting
absentee want to be precise and and
clear here you got a vote this guy out
this guy is disgusting this guy like
many Republicans uses civility and tone
as a political football it's used as a
way to bully people it shouldn't be
allowed and he is one of the most
disgusting extremists in the US Senate
and gay what would it be like getting
him out I mean it would just be such a
victory amazing on so many levels cuz
you if you know that if beta or work
wins that means Democrats probably are
taking the Senate and also a loss here
in this race would probably mean the end
of Ted Cruz's political career probably
know that he wants to run for president
again I mean he knows that a few times
and you kind of have to hold on to that
Senate seat if you're gonna do that it
kind of would also be a loss for Trump
because even though Trump coined the
term lyin Ted and was very aggressive
against Ted Cruz during the presidential
campaign he since endorsed him and they
had a whole love fest that I
and read about so again now Trump is
behind Cruz Cruz is a trump endorsed guy
at this point and we know Donald Trump
really hates it when the people he
endorses end up losing he ends up going
back and saying well you know in the
primary I was really behind this other
person so I don't really know that I was
an actual strong supporter of Ted Cruz
anyway if that's what he would argue in
this case it would be a loss for Trump
which we love it would be a loss for
Cruz which we love it would be a major
loss for Republicans in the Senate which
we love it would be a win for the people
of Texas and that's the number one
reason why I've been saying for months
at this point that when early voting
starts you've got to go vote for better
or orc early voting has started as of
Monday please go and vote for Beto or
work okay we've got a great show for you
today this is the last show I think I
can say this definitively it gets the
value out of current and soon-to-be
former David Pakman show studios yeah
that's a big one it's a big show today
it is a big show and you can see how
emotional Pat is over it we will be
moving studios and the new studio will
be soundproof so there will hopefully be
no more as I like to call it we will
hopefully have we will have Internet
that is 10 10 times faster ten times
faster than the internet that we have
here which is going to be a great thing
means that our members will get their
programming earlier on in the day
because the uploads will take less time
we've just got great stuff coming up and
just a new set you know it's been a few
years since we've changed everything
over yes I do want to warn people the
set is a work in progress so just
because we're out of here today doesn't
mean that on Monday the new set will be
fully done and ready but it will be soon
it will be soon
send me your thoughts about the move
send me your thoughts about civility
send me your thoughts about anything I'm
on twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show